i day trade attention there's plenty of
time get [ __ ] done I'm gonna make Monday
morning my [ __ ] one of the things that
I need to expand on in a in a 20-17
marketing conversation is the variable
of Facebook creative in its ROI
something that is I'm tapping into is
that 90% of digital execution is garbage
and so I think a lot of people hear me
talk and they don't hear that I say do
Superbowl because I think it's under
placed attention i day trade attention I
stand here today as a marketer that
trades attention and I believe that the
number one deal in marketing today is
actually a Super Bowl commercial it's
six million dollars but the entire
country whether they watch it on YouTube
or during the game will know exactly
what you're up to
now most people [ __ ] it up because they
try to make some funny video for 30
seconds and then we forget but that is
to me the number one play I think they
don't hear me say do live read I Heart
Radio because radio is under priced and
I think what they do here is that
Facebook is magically going to work
because it's under press attention that
is true Facebook will give you the best
that bat in my opinion to hit all
Americans at the best price the problem
is the creative if it's a shitty kind of
blurry picture if it's a if it's a
picture from a print ad if it's a video
that you use as a pre-roll advertising
or a video that you
that was actually your TV commercial
you're gonna lose so the elevated
conversation that I need to force myself
into and and my audience and as a matter
of fact right now if I can get approval
d-roc your charge from some of our
clients I'd like to clip in some of the
creative we've done at Vayner for them
that I think fits that mold last time
treading water oh sure sure
[Music]
because let me tell you you start
quitting now you'll quit the rest of
your life and what does never win
and what has never published
[Music]
soccer is the one sport that I love to
do but I'm not 100% sure I'd want to
play anymore part of me feels like I'm
different from others and that I
shouldn't be doing things that I love
because I was born without fingers on my
left hand
[Music]
he is just like everybody else but
Dawson is having his doubts about soccer
he helped his team get to the finals and
he was benched before the championship
game
maybe I wasn't meant to play this maybe
they are right
that I'm not good enough to do it
the number to play in the world is
Facebook video because I believe that
Facebook video not confined to 30
seconds has the ability to build
enormous awareness vaynermedia had a
very special thing happened last week I
don't know if any of you guys caught
this but when the Cubs won the World
Series
we ran who's from Chicago
finally right [ __ ] 108 when the Cubs won
the World Series we ran an ad an ad
after the World Series first it was Nike
then it was us and we brought back Harry
Caray from a classic 1984 commercial and
that went big next day we deployed a
two-minute plus video where Harry Caray
we took 30 years of him calling games
and chopped it up and had him over
two-minute video call the final out of
the Cubs winning the World Series
already
bouncing ball throw
[Applause]
that's the work we need to be talking
about more because the creative is the
variable once you have my attention
you've got to get me excited to buy your
thing and we have not had enough
conversation in the marketplace around
the modern Facebook commercial this 1 2
3 4 5 minute video that is a story that
is compelling people to get excited
about a product or service or mission
this is now the television and the
television is now the radio and Facebook
and Instagram and snapchat are ABC NBC
BBC and Sky and whether you're a startup
or a b2b company or a contra preneur or
a corporation you need to figure out how
to make the best shows on those networks
I feel like I've even been too general
and I will push harder much harder to
make sure that people recognize how
important that creative is and that's
when you know just friendship hopefully
is spending more money on television and
I'm just sitting here saying ok they
definitely could have done better if
they put all that media money and to
tell them into Facebook I just genuinely
believe that but I was like but why
would television work better than
Facebook if that was a bake-off and the
answer is even though it'd be still
gonna be a crappy 30-second commercial
it isn't absolutely true that they could
have made a very crappy even crappier
even crappier commercial video on
Facebook and then that would be the
reason that television could outperform
Facebook in a here's four million
dollars here's four million dollars
bake-off the creative is the variable
and and that debate and and our
attention to the good creative and the
great videos that drive business results
needs to absolutely happen for
marketers big and small to be successful
in the new environment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]